ich werde auch auf jeden fall keinen fuß
mehr in so etwas noch einmal gesagt für
dieses video empfehle ich euch auch geht
auf keinen fall ein
was geht ab und herzlich willkommen bei
einem neuen video ja leute ich hoffe
natürlich jedes gut wir haben schon sehr
spät und heute entweder ein video ich
bin ultra- gespannt wo ich ankommen wird
oder auch wiesbaden kommen wird weil ich
muss ganz ehrlich sagen ich hatte diese
idee schon so lange ich war das bestimmt
schon von einem jahr oder so mal für
euch produzieren oder ausprobieren
allerdings habe ich dann so von
verschiedenen seiten gehört jung
vielleicht ist es gerade nicht so gut
weil das war diese zeit wo viele
youtuber so dieses glücksspiel
ungekennzeichnet in videos hatten also
als werbung und keine ahnung da gab's
einen ziemlich großen geschützturm meine
idee war allerdings und zwar hab das ja
wahrscheinlich schon im titel gelesen es
geht heute um spielothek an dieser
stelle auch schöne grüße an meine eltern
in der mittlerweile auch schon über 18
und ich habe auch viele freunde die ab
und zu mal halt in die spiele gehen so
allerdings bin ich gar nicht also ich
war noch nie selber vor dem automaten
ich habe es auch schon mal über die
schulter geguckt und auch so bisher
mitgefiebert wenn leute halt da wirklich
geld gewonnen haben aber selber habe ich
so nie ausprobiert und man sagt ja immer
so anfängerglück und sowas deswegen habe
ich gedacht wir probieren das heute
mache ich bin absolut also ihr braucht
euch keine sorgen machen dass irgendwie
spielsüchtig werden oder so das gilt
auch für euch lasst die finger davon ich
teste das jetzt noch mal fürs video und
wir schauen war ich habe eben 20 euro
von der von der bank abgeholt
wie viel wir damit erreichen können und
ob wir da plus oder minus machen heute
das ding ist ganz klar am ende gewinnt
immer die bank oder die spielothek man
auch immer möchte deswegen an sich außer
ich habe wieder mal so sportwetten
gemacht aber das heißt ja nicht
sämtliche form von glücksspiel kann ich
keinem empfehlen wie gesagt heute nur
fürs video schaut gerne oder euch das
video an und ich bin mal gespannt wie
das jetzt gleich ablaufen wird
ich habe noch keine ahnung
wenn man so spielt wie hier ich kenne
nur alles spitze henderson ja du kannst
du keine ahnung irgendwas mit freispielt
versuchen wir müssen natürlich ein
bisschen aufpassen mit filmen weil wir
wollen ja nicht rausfliegen
du darfst ja nicht in der spielothek
filmen und ja ist einfach noch mal so
ein kleines experiment ich habe schon
viele videos dazu auf youtube gesehen wo
youtuber halb so was mal getestet habe
ich hoffe ich bekomme dafür jetzt keinen
allzu großen hater aber ich ziehe das
jetzt durch also ich hatte das in meinem
video plan ist ring machen das auch
leisten
das wäre es hier auch keine hollywood
produktionen oder irgendwie so eine
krasse dokumentation ich habe euch ein
gutes video von tomato alex dazu in der
video beschreibung verlinkt ja das ist
mir sehr ausführlich getestet wir machen
das wirklich nur einmal ganz stumpf ich
meine bei mir gibt's ja auch jeden tag
video 19 uhr deswegen können wir leider
nicht die heftigste qualität erwarten
aber ich gehe mit dazu gehören wir sehen
uns ein auto und ich haben uns gerade
noch mal so ein bisschen darüber
unterhalten weil wir waren ja mal
zusammen was hast und du hast einmal so
versucht zu spielen
jetzt allerdings einen dollar pro
drücker dafür so schmerzhaft und auch du
hast nie etwas geworden meinte ok
deswegen also ich bin wirklich mal so
gespannt ob ich da komplett also ich
will halt entweder einen gewinn erzielen
oder halt komplett die 20 euro
verballern sogar oder keine ahnung wenn
ich so 40 haben haben solche wir
überlegen jetzt mal nur vielleicht ist
das ja dann würde ich so kraus
gewöhnliche 40 mit dem rad ja eigentlich
sagt man immer so du musst dir ein limit
setzen und wenn du das limit verzockt
hast dann gehst du raus
das waren sicher was heute wird und ab
wieviel plus würdest du raus gehen wenn
ich das doppelte aus als würde ich
glaube ich ausgibt obwohl dann sitze ich
da wahrscheinlich länger komm mach mal
60 wollte ja ganz nett genau das ja ja
also ich glaube auch ich bin mal
gespannt ob ich dann so weil halt meine
freunde so wenn ihr das sehr schöne
grüße die sitzen da dann und dann haben
die das doppelte raus und dann wird
natürlich weiter gezockt und ab und zu
kommt auch mal eine menge warum aber
meistens fällt dann wieder auf null
dann denke ich mir auch mal ganz gut wir
sind einen kleinen die haben die spieler
rund um die uhr geöffnet wäre ich gucke
mir jetzt gerade noch hier so ein
kleines tutorial an damit ich das mal
checken
also war das spiel das kenne ich so ein
bisschen halt von meinen freunden
das heißt alles spitze oder so der
teufel wenn er kommt ist ein ganzer
kontostand sozusagen wieder auf null
und wenn zum beispiel die münze kommt
oder der käfer oder das kleeblatt so die
stapeln sich einander und ein gewinn
verdoppelt sich dann immer sozusagen
also nicht verdoppelt er steigert sich
dann immer hier oben siehst du diese
weiterhin genau die kommen
hintereinander desto höher wird aber es
kann immer sein dass hier der teufel der
guckt da schon groß so dass der teufel
ja immer mal kommt und dann ist ein ganz
einfacher und du kannst halt den betrag
annehmen oder weiter drücken leute und
dass wir da hinter mir das ist das giga
center und da haben wir zwei mal gerade
wirklich so ein uhr morgens oder so ich
setzte mich jetzt hier hin und dem film
also möchten wir sind jetzt hier in der
spieler und ich fühle mich relativ cool
im juristischen trick angewendet damit
es nicht auffällt dass wir was auch im
spiel ich kann perfekte position also
leute ich versuche dass an manchen
stellen einfach nach zu kommentieren ich
habe 20 euro eingeschmissen irgendwie
hat der automat das erst nicht
angenommen da kam immer wieder geld raus
damit ist jetzt alles spitze das spiel
nicht alles gut
nein
dazu
hier
wir wollen die leute vom fach
und ja ich muss auch zugeben ich habe
mich an vielen stellen wirklich gefreut
wenn man wenn man geld gewonnen hat man
halt so ein kleines glücksgefühl und das
ist glaube ich gerade das schlimme
11 12 euro james einer 12 euro mein
gesamter anderen und spaß macht sich
niemand nach
das anfühlt
ja leute bei diesem spiel ging es halt
immer darum diese leiter hoch zu drücken
und ich hab es ja gerade schon gesagt
ich weiß nicht ob du mir anfängerglück
war am anfang schaut einfach weiter
nicht fertig man muss auf jeden fall
sagen ich bin fast auf 20 euro hoch
gekommen und jetzt werde ich eigentlich
gnadenlos immer weiter runter gezogen
also ich hab es natürlich war schneller
das video jetzt bin ich zum beispiel nur
noch bei acht euro bei 7 euro
heute wir sind gleich wieder arbeiten
sind wir noch bei der hälfte aber so
langsam habe ich den dreh raus nicht
verstehen ich verstehe jetzt wie es geht
die sonne wenn die kommt ich glaube das
ist das beste wurde mir so erklärt
jetzt hier konnten ich bin nur noch bei
4 euro jetzt wieder bei 6 also das
schwankt halt immer von keine ahnung das
ist halt die suchtgefahr dannemann
gewinnt wieder was dann verliert man
wieder dann will man mehr
12 euro schon wieder gemacht
also ich war schon wieder fast bei 20
euro obwohl ich vorher gerade mal noch
vier hatte das geht halt so extrem
schnell und jetzt bin ich gleich einfach
wieder bei 4 23 21 30
und hier kann man sehen ich war wirklich
sehr lange bei niedrigen beträgen
gefallen es hat immer zwischen 5 und 1
euro gespannt und ich dachte okay jetzt
gleich ist es vorbei und dann kam die
show des alex wie viel spaß
ich glaub's nicht wünschen wieder meinen
namen jetzt das machen also wirklich ist
für mich hier richtig richtig
welche krise
[Musik]
also hier seht ja diese leiter die immer
zwischen vier euro also zwischen 400 und
800 schwankt und dann muss man immer
drücken und dann bleibt die entweder bei
400 oder 800 stehen und dann kann man
den betrag teilen und weiter auf dieser
leiter drücken also ich habe das spiel
jetzt mittlerweile echt gut verstanden
und das habe ich jetzt halt hier in
dieser aufnahme gemacht und habe den
betrag von anfangs glaube ich zwölf euro
hochgespielt geben wir das extrem gut
funktioniert
so macht man das richtige nach traum von
mir
vor 40 euro kosten also man kann jetzt
sagen ich war wirklich nicht zu gierig
wie auch immer ich bin jetzt bei 44 euro
also ich bin mit 20 euro reingegangen
und habe jetzt hier 44 euro kann ich
mein auto fast von abbezahlen
ok wieder zurück im auto
ich muss sagen also ich weiß wie lang
war mit der aktion bestimmt 40 minuten
aber ich habe sich 40 minuten und was
halt krass war ich war dreimal kurz vor
0 und bin jetzt am ende doch mit 44 euro
ausgegangen keine ahnung wie ich dachte
eigentlich es war nur 36 aber da lagen
noch so knapp sechs euro
in dieser schale die ich gar nicht mehr
rein geschmissen habe deswegen hoffe ich
mehr als das doppelte rausgeholt und das
war jetzt aber auch auf jeden fall daran
war ich nicht zu gierig waren ja ich hab
das ja am anfang erklärt ich glaube wenn
leute da immer dann mehr wollen wird man
da sehr schnell süchtig ich werde auch
auf jeden fall keinen fuß mehr in sivas
setzen zwar noch einmal gesagt für
dieses video empfehle ich euch auch geht
auf keinen fall rein natürlich kann man
mal gewinnen aber das kann auch ganz
schnell anders aussehen bei mir was
jetzt wahrscheinlich bisschen
anfängerglück ja es ist nicht gemerkt
dass du auch nur ein zimmer über wird
als die gewinne kam ist dieser teil war
ja klar da habe ich hier auch mehr so
naja aber so im endeffekt kann genau
dich das umbringen so ja also lasst die
finger davon verspricht wir das bitte
ich habe jetzt mal einen kleinen
einblick versucht zu geben so sieht das
heute aus und die ganzen sucht lissabon
hat gesehen wir eine geyer der neben uns
das es jetzt direkt am automaten weil
ich da was gewonnen hab ne hoffentlich
verliert er alles nehmen obwohl
eigentlich spielszenen auch gar nicht
viel gewinnen so war es eigentlich mit
dem video ich hoffe es hat euch gefallen
wie gesagt nehmen das jetzt bitte nicht
zu ernst dass ich mal so so etwas ja
umstrittenes thema behandelt habt lasst
nach oben da jeden tag zum 19 den video
game instagram ab da ist die alex ii und
glocke anstellen und den kanal
abonnieren das ist so war superwichtig
okay das war's jetzt richtig